I mean this is not even a question but
Linux is an open source is everywhere
these days but desktop is still you know
but Google day
well actually I mean crap looks like
getting pretty you can run Debian apps
on Chromebooks now they have started a
project well they've story I'm not I
mean crouton has been around for a while
but now the official Google support for
running Debian apps is starting to kind
of trickle out I haven't actually used
it yet yeah I think it's it's pretty new
I only use Chromebooks for calendaring
it's it seems to be that yeah
Chromebooks and an Android are the path
towards the desktop but does yeah but
does it really matter nowadays because
we are doing most of working cloud and I
I think it still matters I mean I so
it's a lot of people still use the
desktop not everybody uses a cloud right
I still wish we were better at and
having a standardized desktop that goes
across all the distributions there's
been some progress there I mean this is
not a kernel issue so this is just like
more of a personal annoyance how the
fragmentation of the different vendors
have I think held the desktop back of it
but there has been some progress on that
front too with flat pack and things like
but I'm still optimistic but it's been
25 years it's going to be another few
years even with the the flat pack there
is a pin edge and then there is you know
so there's a yeah now the desktop is not
there because if there's one format then
Linux will be treated as one platform
not multiple platform that I don't me
have to say and that maybe were crown
crown books end up doing is that maybe
that will turn into a de facto standard
for for desktop applications one
Chromebook start just
Debian packages or something we'll see I
do more like Chrome OS is the desktop
environment and you're running you know
so yeah I mean what I do
I would actually not mind having a
Chromebook but right now my main problem
is even when you can run native Linux on
Chromebooks
with crouton or or something you can't
do the kernel testing right which is
what I care about so so it's it's at the
point where I can kind of see where I
could use a Chromebook in a few years
but not it you know but it's not there
yet
you